[Music]
you've been chosen as a champion to
represent your Wizarding House in a
deadly duel against two rival magic
schools your opponents are fearsome from
the Newton at school a powerful sorcerer
wields a wand that can turn people into
fish but his spell only works 70% of the
time
and from the live Tennille an even more
powerful enchantress wields a wand that
turns people to statues and it works
90% of the time lots are drawn and
you're chosen to cast the first spell in
the duel the Newton its magician will go
second and the lighten enchantress third
after which you'll repeat casting in
that order
until only one of you is left the rules
of magic duels are strict and anyone who
casts out of order immediately forfeits
the duel also to prevent draws the rules
stipulate that if everyone's still
standing at the end of the first round
you'll all be turned into cats now you
must choose a wand your Wizarding house
presents you with three options the
banneker which binds one target with
vines and casts effectively 60% of the
time the gaussian which turns one target
into a tree and works 80% of the time
and the incredibly rare Notah 9000 which
banishes one target to a distant
mountaintop and casts perfectly 100
percent of the time your opponents are
masters of strategy as well as sorcery
and you know they'll make the choices
that maximize their own chances of
success which one should you choose and
what strategy should you employ to have
the greatest chance of winning the duel
you reach for the nur - 9000 first after
all it makes sense to enter the duel
with the most powerful wand but before
you pick it up you consider what would
happen as the most dangerous wizard
you'd also be the target of the other
two magicians and you'd need to take
care of the most dangerous of them first
but afterward there's a 70% chance you'd
be struck down by the remaining wizard
that's trouble maybe it's better to take
the Gaussian it works 80% of the time
which means you wouldn't be a target
until the Enchantress was incapacitated
but if you succeeded in transforming her
you'd probably be turned into a fish
immediately after if you transformed the
sorcerer The Enchantress would almost
certainly turn you to stone it would
really be better if you missed and
that's when you have an idea what if you
took the Gaussian then missed on purpose
then you would wait for the sorcerer to
attack the Enchantress and you'd have an
80% chance of winning against the
sorcerer it's a good idea but there's a
problem
the sorcerer could also pass his turn
and The Enchantress knowing that she
couldn't pass without becoming a cat
would cast her spell on one of you
and since you're the most dangerous
between you and the sorcerer you'd be
the target and that's when you see what
you really need to do take the weakest
wand the banneker and miss on purpose
now the sorcerer knows that he'll be
targeted by the Enchantress and he'll
have to try to turn her into a fish to
avoid being turned into stone 70% of the
time he'd succeed and you'd have a 60%
chance of winning the duel at the
beginning of the next round if he fails
chances are he'll be turned to stone and
you'd still have a 60% chance of winning
the duel against the Enchantress there's
a slim 3% chance you'll all be turned
into cats but when everything is
accounted for you have better than even
odds of winning with this strategy and
that's the best you can do here's what
the probability of winning for the
different strategies looks like
who would have thought that the best way
to take your shot would be to throw away
your shot
hungry for more deadly duels try this
one out
you and your opponent have to choose
between two bowls of five apples each in
the green bowl two of the apples are
poisonous and in the red bowl three are
but if you choose the green bowl you'll
have to eat three of the apples at
random and if you choose the red bowl
you'll have to eat two at random here's
the catch
eat one poisonous Apple and you'll be
fine but two will kill you
which Bowl should you choose or does it
not even matter our sponsor brilliant
org will help you develop the skills to
survive any battle of whit's life throws
at you they'll guide you on how to break
down a problem into its component pieces
think clearly through each part and
build it back up to a conclusion hone
your instincts at brilliant org slash
ted-ed
and use that link so they know we sent
you better yet the first 833 of you who
sign up for a premium subscription will
get 20% off the annual fee and if you
sign up for brilliant using the link in
the description below brilliant will
email you the solution to their Apple
riddle